yo yo what's up GQ I'm mes the Jeweler
and today I'm going to break down some
of the more affordable watches worn by
celebrities
today Timothy
sham we have Timothy shalam rocking a
cardier panther it's a higher end piece
but it's not crazy it's very subdued and
he's actually wearing a lady size which
I like also he makes other men feel
comfortable rocking a piece like this
there's a way more affordable as you can
see I have a ladies Rolex over here so
will only cost you around the $4,000
leaving my shop as opposed to getting a
36 mm and paying close to $7,000 on a
piece like this he makes it cool to rock
something like this and you're saving a
lot more money there cardio Panther
retails for around 4K but you can find
vintage ones like this for closer to the
two grand range will
farell over here we have will frell
wearing a orus propilot x400 has a
little pinkish shoe to it which the
first thing that that I thought was the
Oyster Perpetual Rolex of course for
these special colors you can be pink a
much higher price and this orus is very
similar to it and you're going to pay 1%
of the price you would pay for the Rolex
I think he wore this one at the Barbie
uh at the Barbie Premiere which I love
that he he got creative and he wore
something that has that pinkish Hue at
the Barbie Premiere he's having fun with
everything if you're looking to spend
under $5,000 for a gorgeous watch this
one cost close to $4,000 I'm a Rolex guy
so if I were to buy any watch at that5
,000 range and under I go with a simple
Rolex dayjust 36 mm this one I would let
go for $4,000 right now this is a 1601
vintage piece nice tight band it's not
like you're going to get something
that's crazy beat up and barely wearable
you going get some of these gorgeous
pieces that are extremely durable and
made to last a life time Tyler
Creator he's always doing something cool
something different definitely a very
fashionable guy you know Tyler Creator
he's known for his crazy cardier this it
a Casio quartz which very classic rubber
strap I like the the patina dial a
little patina yellow dial is kind of
cool a Casio like this uh you can find
this for under $30 very cool very sporty
Tyler creat is rocking in a luxurious
way costed him basically a sandwich and
some uh and some chips kid
Cy we got a kit Cy rocking his G-Shock
Vape watch extremely colorful extremely
fun uh you see he's rocking it with his
pink hair very uh retro Vibe which this
is more my style so if I were to go for
an affordable watch this is definitely
the first one on my list that's the cool
thing with G-Shock is that it's a watch
that was done for the military something
that you see soldiers wearing and then
you got somebody like kid Cy who's an
aess celebrity rocking this court side
G-Shock is an abbreviation for
gravitational shock the G-Shock was
basically designed to just be an
extremely resistant watch something that
you can uh literally fight Wars with or
go hiking with or uh do all this crazy
stuff so for a very small amount of
money you can get something that will be
very durable something that'll probably
last you a lifetime just needs a battery
change once in a while G-Shocks are
Timeless watches you got a Spike Lee
rocking one courts side at the Knicks
game wearing the Knicks colors cool
thing about gshock go is they're always
doing these collaborations with
celebrities there was a collab with Ed
shiran that I really loved there was
this like yellow and black gshock which
again pops always be on the lookout for
some of these cool collaborations that
G-Shock does you know some of these uh
Pieces Just Like Rolex goes uh for a
premium these g-shot collabs also go for
almost double to Triple premiums over
its retail value Steph
Curry greatest shooter of all time Steph
Curry luxury clean Sleek you have the um
Mavado Museum classic watch and I love
it it kind of reminds me of the Onyx
dial that Rolex does but it's not going
to break your bank you have here a
Mavado that has no hour markers except
for the big gold Circle at 12 and I also
love the shape of the hands I think it's
a very clean watch this is something
that I'll add in a collection any day of
the week it's a lot of watch for a
little amount of money Steve Jobs
got Steve Jobs Here a legend over here
he's wearing a Seiko Quartz honestly
he's making me want to get one right now
looks cool looks vintage looks classic
fire piece and the cool thing is when
you are somebody like Steve Jobs and you
wear this watch his watch went in
auction for
$42,000 making something that was
probably under $100 go for that amount
it shows you that the value is inside
the person not in the watch P
Davidson rocking over here a Casio
classic classic uh Casio look tells the
time digitally and you got that uh that
whole black look it's clean put on his
hoodie threw on that watch and it's a
comfy look it's a lot of watch for uh
for a small amount of price and this one
looks like a G-Shock I actually thought
it was a G-Shock but uh it cost way less
this one will run you around like
$42.95 Mark
wallberg timx it's another uh Legacy
watch brand that makes an affordable
time piece as we see here we got Mark
Wahlberg rocking a $77 timx Iron Man
again cool look sleek black subdued I
like to tell the time digitally
sometimes you don't got to look so deep
into seeing where the hand is at and
everything over here you read the time
it's that easy Jack
Nicholson you have somebody like Jack
Nicholson probably one of the greatest
actors of all time who can afford any
piece sitting here rocking a timx easy
reader you know it's I love it looks
like a classic watch looks like
something that could be expensive if it
said Paddock Philipe but over here it
says Timex and uh it's extremely
affordable and you got Legends like Jack
Nicholson rocking it so why not you Bill
Murray I think Bill Murray got a little
jealous of Jack Nicholson he said I need
one also so over here we got him rocking
also a easy reader a little bit
different than the other one that was
worn this one has the silver second hand
I like the contrast in the watch you
have the white dial you have the silver
bezel and the silver lugs with the black
hands and the black numbers I think it's
a nice contrast this is a everyday watch
to rock and enjoy we have all the
rappers now rocking two watches on the
wrist I think Bill Murray is the first
one to do it he's got a cardier on his
left hand he's got a timx on his right
hand I love it Trend Setter Ronnie
Chang sometimes the biggest Flex is uh
rocking something that you find in an
antique shop here we have Ronnie Chang
rocking a vintage Mickey Mouse watch
pushing boundaries over here rocking a a
nice velvet green suit jacket and then
he threw on this Mickey Mouse watch you
can tell he's just having fun with it he
said I'm going to come to this classy
event with this Mickey Mouse watch and
uh that's the cool thing with these
watches don't be afraid if you're not a
celebrity don't be afraid to step out of
your comfort zone and do something like
this this is fun and it's definitely a
convo starter at any of these events you
know you don't always have to like rock
NE brand pieces like a lot of people
they show off oh my Richard Mill is
number to 75 you can't find another one
I don't know you're going to find
another one of this vintage Mickey Mouse
is also that's the that's the real Flex
[Music]
here I hope after watching this video
you guys understand that the watch game
is not only for the Rich and Famous it's
for everyone like you and I you can find
yourself some gorgeous watches from
$1100 to $1,000 again knowledge is power
M the Jeweler
[Music]
out